[Musique]
concevoir une nouvelle stratégie de
développement des os au plus près des
partenaires et des porteurs de projets
voilà l'ambition affichée par le
département ce vendredi 9 septembre à
l'occasion d'une réunion sur le site du
domaine archambault au tampon les
vice-présidente laurence mandon béatrice
sigismeau sophie arzal camille klein
ainsi que les conseillères
départementale 6 d'aullène papaya
fabiola la gourde et brigitte apsit ont
participé activement à une séance de
travail et de réflexion avec les acteurs
du territoire nous sommes sur le domaine
archambault au 19e kilomètre à la plaine
des cas dans les eaux effectivement pour
que nos collègues du département puisse
vraiment ça pour plier la volonté du
département de faire un réel
développement des os c'est à dire à la
fois de voir sur le terrain ce qui est
mise en application concrètement avec
des plantations au niveau des plantes
endémiques et médicinales mais également
voir les acteurs du territoire puisque
sur ce domaine il vient aussi un magasin
de producteurs une vente directe du
consommateur au producteur pour qu'il y
ait cette synergie entre les producteurs
les consommateurs et sur réel lien
social que l'on veut aux départements
créés dans différents quartiers dans
différents territoires et si notamment
dans les eaux et pour vraiment que nos
collègues du département puisse
peut-être
je dirais pas faire un copier coller
mais voir ce qui pourrait s'adapter
également sur leur territoire la visite
a débuté avec la présentation du domaine
réhabilité il y à peu par le département
la réhabilitation de la maison a été
décidée en 2012 mais la reconstruction a
été fait de telle manière que conserver
l'aspect architectural de ce bâtiment de
ce lieu on a essayé de conserver un
maximum enfin ce qui était conservable
maximum de matériaux notamment on a
récupéré des carottes et des carreaux de
ciment qu'on a on a mis on a fait un
calepinage juste à l'entrée la plaque
que vous voyez juste affiche heroes
c'est écrit bagatelle on a on a quand
même conservé ce cette appellation à
l'arrière du bâtiment il y avait un
boucan c'est là où on faisait cuire à
manger on a conservé le bâtiment mais on
a donné aux nattes appellation notre
affectation qui est la miellerie agnel
rick on va faire fonctionner avec le
syndicat des apiculteurs de la réunion
on a le projet de rhj et pédagogique
quand on est au stade
programmes normalement les études vont
être lancées d'ici fin d'année pour une
construction la partie travaux je pense
que l'année prochaine le domaine
archambault a l'ambition de créer
davantage de lien social dans le
quartier est de répondre aux besoins des
consommateurs d'acheter local avec sa
boutique de producteurs inauguré le 6
mai dernier qu'on a décidé de mettre en
place ce projet en commun aujourd'hui on
est six agriculteurs qui travaillent
directement dans le domaine et puis on
essaye de travailler elle d'intégrer
encore de nouvelles personnes donc on
aura certainement des producteurs en
conventionnel mais aussi des producteurs
en bio donc aujourd'hui on est prêt à
vous accueillir il ya énormément de
choses dans ce magasin du 26 la hausse
des lentilles de l'escargot des
rillettes de canard des rillettes de
cochon du foie gras des plaintes de
confiture de différents goûts et voilà
on essaye de mettre en avant l'ensemble
des produits identitaires de notre île
et puis de travailler aussi avec des
agriculteurs qui sont au proche
physiquement du magasin la découverte
des travaux de restauration écologique
menée par la spl eden sur l'espace
naturel sensible du domaine étaient
également au programme de cette matinée
d'immersion on est sur un site
patrimonial un espace naturel sensible
de vin d'archambault et donc la sp
l'éden fait de la restauration et la
plantation sur ce site et on a vu les
différentes étapes depuis
l'ensemencement la plante qui qui va
grandir qui va être mis en exposition
dans le milieu naturel pour prendre ses
forces et ensuite être transplantées sur
le site de façon harmonieuse pour
ensuite grandir donc à travers ce
cheminement on voit les différentes
étapes du travail des équipes de espn
pour restaurer
ce domaine d'argent beau donc le
département porte le plan un million
d'arbres et ce projet est un projet
colossal sur une mandature faut savoir
qu'on ne prend pas n'importe quoi la sp
hayden assure une traçabilité
depuis la collecte de la grève jusqu'à
l'implantation donc des différents plans
sur un territoire bien déterminé
cette séance de travail hors les murs
aura permis aux élus de s'imprégner des
besoins et des attentes exprimées par
les acteurs et les riverains l'objectif
étant d'élaborer une stratégie de
développement adaptée est bénéfique pour
les eaux
[Musique]